It's switched on.
Yeah, looking good.
For example.
I've got another one here.
Maybe the all-blue ones won't show up anymore.
That's also possible.
(unclear)
Roman knows about it.
Because I've done a few.
Let's just carry on.
What's it like here?
Good.
So I've pulled up Winterthur again.
Pulled it up.
(unclear)
I've already pulled up Winterthur.
And it's via one of those diagrams.
Because with that you can really see.
And there is.
And you can see when, or rather
in what sense.
Presumably.
Clouds.
So-called (unclear).
Here again I chose the ICON-D2 model.
When you're there.
When you what?
If you want a wider area for Sunday.
Then it's worth using.
The European one.
Or the bigger one.
ICON with 13 kilometres.
In any case.
And with that, into tomorrow.
And you stay on the high side.
(unclear)
ICON in any case.
And then.
(unclear)
And.
Tomorrow morning it looks pretty similar. However, we now have precipitation forecast for later.
So here from 7 o'clock, with the precipitation, more so than the cloud cover, but that
isn't really the cloud cover, with the rest of it still around 10. And also with the
cloud cover, here and still underneath. That's the cloud cover also around 8:30 with
clear precipitation. You can actually see it here too, where you can spot a small clue.
In the lower portion it's just as grey, but you see it then with the (unclear).
That's very good, that's how it is. And now from my point of view it's a bit ambiguous,
but you can clearly see that the cloud cover is closing in from 11 o'clock, for instance
the (peak) is already in the clouds, you can see that clearly from the hatching.
So the mountains, by far the largest part is sitting in the clouds from 11 o'clock onwards,
when we look at the time when there's precipitation, which is generally forecast, then once again
with the time, a bit out there, here it's not really showing proper precipitation
for us yet, the further along it gets, the more cloud cover comes in, but the cloud cover
with the precipitation isn't quite there yet, you can already see that clearly.
So basically by 8 o'clock everyone agrees that the first precipitation
moves in. If you also look here at Pissenhaus, you can check the cloud cover
there, the time too, what I mean, not quite so clearly displayed, if you now
just look at the cloud cover, it looks a bit different by 3 o'clock,
you can see it a bit earlier there, you have to know where you are,
and that's there, at this little kink. And in our region you can make out a bit
more, down there with the time bar, then a bit further back you can see,
where you can see the Bise, the cloud cover there along the peaks, we
are today. But pretty thin as far as the Bise goes, the precipitation comes through,
I've got it there, well it shows that, when the (clouds) hit the ridges and very nicely
clearly and happily displayed. Mainly you just have to look at your own region,
how often it lines up, with the clouds it often fits very, very well,
and sometimes again when it looks different — well, that you have to take with a bit of caution,
so abroad I've had pretty bad results, but here in Switzerland
it fits well more often, but abroad it hasn't been that consistently good,
so I'd say, yeah, you can use it often. With precipitation you can actually go to it as well,
for precipitation work, then there's also the option, with Switzerland,
to add two more overview maps, into the world from above, in the variant,
you can drill in a bit more, and then in the time bar,
we move forward a bit further, it doesn't go all that far ahead, but let's go to it.
Now we see, depending on what time, you can see that the bigger,
the bigger portions keep shifting, and let's see if there at eight,
I'm at two, eight, ten, no and so on, where I'd say now, eight,
I think for us it's still a bit, well, that's debatable,
but there, and I don't think it's right with us,
whether it's earlier or later exactly, I wouldn't bet on that,
but, and so everyone agrees that by the late evening,
the precipitation has moved in, and that from late morning to late afternoon,
and I think, the precipitation, it stays there and quite a bit,
yeah, there, we still see it pulling away a little bit,
always afterwards here or here, that's already here and here in the late evening,
then also, and then, when the Foehn really collapses,
the front comes in, then it starts snowing again.
So this way you can prepare yourself relatively well,
and you can also use the Air Active app, where,
well, I didn't have it up here,
not just the forecast like here,
the actual, only the pre-calculated,
general situation, when that's good,
here, pre-calculated, the general situation,
but alongside that, there's the sounding,
the link to it, for 3,000 metres,
which I put in there, and then in the
analysis, go forward a bit and look,
what's predicted, and if that's the case,
this is the morning's outlook,
this is the morning, this is the morning,
this is the morning,
that's a bit for you,
if you do the radio sounding (radiosonde),
then we can move forward a bit further,
to the 8,000 hour,
then you see that it passes over us.
So on the day, afternoon, evening,
and on the day with the right,
with the calculated forecasts,
and that way you can actually read out quite well,
what it'll be like for Monday morning,
in specific things exactly,
and it's also clearly good for tomorrow with the start,
and now we're at 3,000 hours,
for an outlook,
if we look at 20,000 hours,
that's just a bit further out,
and we could take a look at that as an outlook,
what we don't do.
It's not training material,
but just out of interest,
and what the forecasts look like,
or we'd switch to the European one.
Right, we've still got the wind.
We find the wind from 3,000 m.
And we see
that there's basically no warning issued there,
you don't necessarily have
a red warning dot there, without a proper alert now.
At two or three thousand metres it'll really be less, but the question is still
every (forecast) gives us, maybe even 15 km/h, only northern lean and
launch site.
And now, what's its character at the launch here, you have to know that.
There, I don't know, whether by Sunday afternoon it's with rain and there and there and there and there, and so on, also a bit changeable again, maybe
where the strength here, if we look at Karm, the day on the leeward side, but yeah, still maybe 30 km/h,
still one metre, just by the bad direction, so let's assume that on Sunday too it doesn't look too bad,
that we'd then look further, again a bit of the anchor on Sunday, then you can see if it picks up, then you can pull more out of the ICON-D2.
Yeah, strong wind, we've still got plenty, that the same two and heats up on us.
The last one here for me isn't so good now, but presumably exactly that will occur widely.
Occur.
Occur, well you can imagine that it's more likely the case for us.
Three occur, you can in Karm on the side, not from the side.
So, as an estimate, with me alone then in the pure compared, balanced.
There we still have a count that the one day has been ruling more.
The wind at 2,000 metres, there I'm a bit speculating.
I'm then almost never that kind of winter (wind).
And in the past that hasn't worked out so well.
And where I actually have the rotation tendencies open at the moment, and here at Boerner still cool, the 2,000 metres.
And each of us, that it roughly fits, the 3,000 metres.
That's presumably supposedly going to come in.
And then it'll be tough alone to go off of.
And then I've got one more thing.
Tell me sometime if it works, that we'll also communicate that a bit better.
So, beforehand, now purely the basics about the wind-direction component as the key factor,
if we go to the forecast surface pressure map from the German weather service,
then we have our day.
That's the federal weather large-scale situation.
That goes by the isobars here.
The originator of the large-scale isobar pattern.
If the wind groups now once again definitely aren't always like that, of course.
But if we're moving right along the isobars, then we tend to have non-standard wind there.
And that's basically with these isobars at 3,000 metres.
That's also not that strong.
And if fundamentally I think it's going to be a good day in terms of cloud cover,
then in this kind of service you always have to consider the high fog (Hochnebel).
And of course you can also use the diagrams here to take a look at the high fog.
And when, what its upper limit is, and the one on Sunday goes from 1,700 to 1,800 metres,
that's quite high.
That's presumably one of those days when the high fog even reaches up to us, gets pushed up,
with the strong Bise.
Could that now also be the case for Sunday for us,
if you go very deep into the valleys, it could be, so it's possible.
That's over 1,800 metres.
It's very sunny, and afterwards you're stuck in the high fog.
I think if you prepare a bit with the various apps,
and also compare them, that's always very important on the day itself.
How were the forecasts, did they hold up.
I've done it 7,000 times, that some simply tend to show too much, too much,
because they give too much wind or are also more on the pessimistic side.
But in the end for a pilot that's better than when it's calculated too generously, too positively,
thought of too optimistically, then of course there's
in the motive.
There's a link.
And in the people, in the people to correct.
There's always also (unclear) in the amount.
as a tip to take with you, and with MeteoBlue very, very good. We had in the Iberian once
we pulled it in together, that it'll be hot like that again, present, when the,
I looked at other maps too, which had forecast that. Boerner also in
the Iberian showed complete overcast, all day long. Only MeteoBlue gave us a
cloud base, 2,000 metres, 2,000 metres, and in the end we hardly had any
clouds. So you really have to see what's best for you at that location, and
then maybe just work with two, at most three apps. I'll
introduce you to (unclear) too,
I think for example abroad lots of information, the (snarts)
in the launch sites, or also in some scenes you still get.
In terms of presentation it was already amazingly good, I'd take its word for it.
With a glance and the (trai), that there's information available here.
I wasn't a fan in the beginning, but I'm now convinced that it's a good thing too.
You'd think of the (unclear), the possible landing with the sliding,
over the normal attention and (unclear), or also a special north-launch wagon, anyone can write to me directly.
If you're not entirely sure, where you could look up information again,
rather than each individual app, you can just write to me.
Or look the whole thing up later on the homepage under the active members area,
there I'll upload the presentation.
Yeah, I'd say, from my side that was it, any questions, it would actually still be pretty cool,
if anyone has questions, or if something was unclear, too fast, too little explained beforehand.
You can write that now or raise your hand or just turn the mic on and ask the questions.
You've got a question, I think, right?
Yeah, you asked us earlier, you had the potential high-fog upper limits at the German weather service,
where did you find that?
Right, well, I'll send you the link.
That's super, perfect.
Wonderful.
Because that's still good to save.
Now, when you receive high-quality forecasts, those are simply data from the German weather service.
Good, other questions, also, also those kinds of things, of course welcome, and if anything is still unclear
.
Okay, so we'd say, as your task, clearly look tomorrow how we now (look at) the
large (unclear)
and whether the forecasts held up, that we looked at today, did it occur with the precipitation in the evening between 18, 19, 20 o'clock.
That's something you have to compare tomorrow, maybe take a look, our station isn't working right now,
but the (measuring) station at 200,000 metres DG, you could also use that, what's the wind there.
That's 2,500 metres, then it shows up, if it's around 20 to 30 km/h wind, then the forecast is also good
and has actually held up well too.
So that's what we can do tomorrow, and I also recommend that to you for the future,
maybe also for days that aren't flyable, just look at what forecast you made and what actually
occurred. Because that way you can improve and learn and notice, this is very good,
this wasn't quite so good.
For our region there's one thing I noticed, many still have more (unclear),
but then at our place in our region, that doesn't really work, so for that you have to draw on your own experience
and today, yeah.
Gather experience. That's important. Thanks very much for the time.
Thanks too. Have a nice evening.
Thanks. Thanks.
Bye. Bye.
Ciao. Ciao.